liebe zuschauer vor zwei wochen hat uns
unser freund zeug an aus der türkei
erzählt dass man in der türkei sagt
kommen wir zahlen wie die deutschen wenn
man sagen will dass man getrennt zahlt
daraufhin haben wir angefangen zu
diskutieren welche sprichworte gibt es
noch in der welt die deutsche oder
deutschland beinhalten und wir haben
euch gefragt in der community section
auf youtube habt ihr uns sehr sehr sehr
viele sprüche geschrieben und ich lese
heute diese sprüche janisch vor
er hat sie noch nicht gewesen bist du
bereit mehr ich träume schon toni aus
bulgarien schreibt in bulgarien sagt man
es punktuell esse german ja das ist sehr
populär
populäre meinung dass die deutschen sehr
pünktlich sind sind sie ihn eigentlich
kleine ich so pünktlich aber aber sie
sind schon stolz darauf pünktlich zu
sein auch wenn sie es nicht sind
mohammed schreibt in einer sprache die
ich nicht kenne
kat band funky almani you look like
girls heißt in diesem in dieser sprache
you look amazing total außergewöhnlich
ja im polnischen gibt es auch einen
spruch und das bezieht sich auf und
sagte der teufel der erscheint der ist
nach einer deutschen mode gekleidet aber
dabei ist diese friedrich die große mode
diese 17
der jahrhundert mode gemeint die
deutschen wie der teufel aus ungefähr
[Musik]
spacex sagt und das ist ein krasser
beitrag almanya was in the world the
germans alot of people would run to
escape the fate of the german is
watching you
das ist traurig im grunde word vorgebe
resch im finish ist jahns axa pigs
german also wenn man auf finnisch sagen
will ich verstehe nur bahnhof sagt man
es verstehen nur pigs german was
bedeutet pigs main afp x2014 der raschen
would kill the german bestimmt wieder
wodka gemeinde der ist interessant die
option schreibt koreaner und sagen
arbeit und das wird auf koreanisch auch
arbeit ausgesprochen aber es bedeutet in
koreanisch teilzeitarbeit der koreaner
benutzt das deutsche wort arbeit um
arbeit zu bezeichnen die nur zur hälfte
also nur teilzeit ist und wo sie ist die
deutsche referenzen zu dabei
es hat was unter dem koreanischen
arbeitskultur zu tun dass die die also
die deutsche arbeit ist nur die hälfte
von dem was der koreaner macht die
koreaner arbeiten wahrscheinlich zu viel
vermute ich schreibt mir gerne wenn es
anders ist norman schreibt in singapur
heißt nennt man einen furz german gas
[Gelächter]
das ist lustig weil die vielen deutschen
machen sich da nicht wirklich so viel
daraus ja als nutzen was habe ich schon
so oft
und komischerweise in polen sagt man
auch der deutsche furzt am tisch und
dann verlässt er den raum ich habe nie
verstanden warum es lustig ist
wahrscheinlich all diese abstrakte
gedanken dann sagt man ihm wollen ja
dass er nicht nur das er furzt sondern
dann war sie lässt ja die leute mit
seinem kurz noch dasitzen und traurig
ist dass ich weiß es nicht
jean-marc sagt in gries the military
service ist oppliger terry nightshift
between two info s college germanicus
versteh's nicht ganz sich also die
schlimmste oder die schwierigste zeit
des tages ist deutsch ja im sinne von
art
harte nicht einfach aus zu stehen
red day in brazil every day is because
of the tree marke buell game das
fußballspiel rechnung hatte 7 zu 1 gegen
brasilien gespielt ich war dabei ich
habe es gesehen
es war ein sehr großer tag in
deutschland ja das war auch ein großer
tag für uns weil wir eben interviewt
haben der das vorausgesehen hat also die
brasilianer erinnern sich immer noch
immer wenn es ihnen schlecht geht
erinnern sie sich an dieses schlechtes
spiel musste war nur ein zufall
die deutschen verdienen das nicht brazil
dr jashari schreibt in aserbaidschan
der ist in expression call stimmen exakt
ja hoffentlich baugrube schreibt goodwin
requires im exploration in poland is
waiting to be used german brand carlson
companies which springer von germany for
the german watch the polish customer
centers in germany says the german cross
selling
ich kenne das auch nicht
ich finde es ein sehr schönes bild
vinzenz schreibt in herchen kreol die
hefte expression monza sonst ballmann
habe ich wahrscheinlich falsch
ausgesprochen rutscht translate bis
person ist die german horse meaning that
person hesse big bad in der maske jay
anderson total war also ein
in haiti wird eine person mit einem
großen arsch aber deutscher genannt
welches pferd ja toll ist das jetzt ein
kompliment ich glaube nicht ich glaube
schon aber diese im static entgeht mir
quasi aber es ist interessant zu
bemerken dass aha da gibt es andere
ästhetische empfindungen und sehr schön
theo schreibt iza sulu in south africa
er ist in expression for someone who is
good at what they do that seems as no
but i can't stop this weekend interpret
sfv dann wenn wir in metal in germany
woodward woodward woodward also wenn
jemand ihn schlagen kann dann wird sich
in deutschland das metall verbiegen
wow ja aber deutsche qualität war sehr
lange richtig berühmt und bekannt
das witzige ist ich habe das letztens in
einer dokumentation gesehen dass dieses
made in germany es wurde eigentlich von
den briten eingeführt um eigentlich die
schlechte qualität zu kennzeichnen von
messern die nach deutschland nach
england importiert wurden
und sie wollten damit quasi die deutsche
qualität labeln damit die leute das
nicht verwechseln mit der guten
englischen qualität und dummerweise hat
sich dass ausgerechnet durchgesetzt als
ein qualitätszeichen ja prima bis heute
offensichtlich in aller welt populär
deutsche qualität fassen wir zusammen
deutsche sind dafür bekannt dass sie
angeblich hart arbeiten was gar nicht
stimmt dass dafür das sie eingehen
pflicht pünktlich sind was auch nicht
stimmt nicht unbedingt und dass sie viel
scheiße im krieg gemacht haben was
stimmt ja ja das wollen wir nicht
relativieren ich fand es sehr
interessant ja nicht ich kann das auch
sehr interessant ich fand es vor allem
interessant dass uns leute wirklich aus
der ganzen welt geschrieben haben aus
von carlos tann bis haiti von brasilien
bis nach finnland und und südafrika und
überall gibt es irgendetwas was
irgendwie als ein bild ist was man mit
deutschland verknüpft
finde ich super fand ich auch es wundert
mich aber nicht ich kann mir vorstellen
nämlich dass es genauso viele
ausstellungen gibt mit franzosen mit
engländer mit norweger mit vielen
weil jede nation hat sich irgendwo
bemerkbar gemacht im in welche lage aber
die deutschen sind schon eine eine
riesige
zivilisation zentrum eins der vielen
anderen aber an sich auch eine sehr
starke starke geschichte starke nation
wird willkommen zivilisations zentrum
deutschland ist ja so
wir denken ja er soll geschichtlich was
war im siebzehnten jahrhundert
achtzehnten jahrhundert und da war
deutschland unheimlich stark mit dem mit
der industrialisierung mit der
wissenschaften die dann bedeutendes
geleistet haben und sehr viel davon
kommt aus deutschland
danke schön ist deine zeit sehr gerne
ich hoffe es hat ihr spaß gab es hat mir
spaß gemacht ja das kam überzeugend
rüber und jetzt freuen wir uns auf eure
kommentare schreibt uns doch mal hier
unten ob ihr noch andere sprüche kennt
mit deutschen oder ob wir vielleicht
eine meinung habe zu dem was wir vor
gelesen haben und wir freuen uns diese
woche ganz besonders wenn ihr unsere eps
ziel lag noch ausprobiert wenn ihr lust
habt damit weiter deutsch zu lernen
dort könnt ihr unter anderem vokabeln
lernen und zwar auf eine strukturierte
weise wir haben einen vokabeltrainer mit
über 4.500 vokabeln und ihr könnt den
durchgehen könnte dort verschiedene
übungen machen zudem vokabeln und immer
wieder diese vokabeln in einem
bestimmten abstand trainieren so dass
sie wirklich in eurem gedächtnis bleiben
motiviert dass man aus und lasst uns
einen kommentar
danke fürs zuschauen danke ich bedanke
mich auch und bis nächste woche
das war yannis ski und sein seine
imitation einer technischen störung